in this game dev course varnos games
will teach you how to build games with
unreal engine 5. you will also learn how
to use the blueprint visual scripting
system that makes it simpler to create
gameplay elements
hey guys thank you so much for checking
this course out
this is going to be a very very beginner
level unreal engine 5 blueprints only
course we're going to make a simple game
called the battery man so if i play this
game what's going to happen is
i have a few batteries present all
around the scene i have to collect these
batteries over here
and once that's done i either go to the
new level or i win the game so here this
is my second level
and if i collect these batteries i have
my wind condition
and i always have a loose condition too
so if i wait it out
if i don't collect any of these
batteries over here
and wait for five seconds
i lose the game i can quit if i want and
if i can retry
uh we obviously still we have main menu
too so we're going over everything in
this game including uh ui we're taking a
look at when conditions animations
recording everything from scratch we're
using the third person template but
we're not using any of their built-in
movement we're going to create our own
character add our own functionality to
these to this character so it's going to
be a game that you have
hey guys and welcome back
now we will take a look at android
engine 5 and um try to create our own
project
so what what you have to do is open up
your epic games launcher
and
epic games launcher is essentially a
poster to unreal engine and its
marketplace so if i'm if i let's take a
look at the marketplace over here
so the marketplace essentially has all
these different high quality assets that
i can use and one thing i love about the
marketplace is that it has something
called the free for the month um part
where it it chooses five feet assets
from the asset store from the
marketplace and it provides the users of
one religion um
these assets for absolutely free so that
is an amazing feature and that's why i
love uh the undulation marketplace it
has a lot of different high quality
assets and even epic games most of it
most of the content epic games provides
it's completely free and you can use it
in your game um
so try to check out the marketplace and
use this in your game
it's not cheating it's actually an
amazing thing that you'll know how to
use other people's assets on your game
because that's how game development
actually works
let's try and see how to install unreal
engine 5 now if i open up my games
launcher and open this ue5 part over
here
it has my early acc it says under engine
5 early access uh now under engine 5 is
not complete which is why it still says
it's in early access but i can download
my early access from here
and i can also get the sample project
that
that they showed in the under religion
five showcase video uh which is amazing
but once you once you're done installing
unreal engine 5 if you go to your
library you will see your unreal engine
5 editor over here and i can open it up
and over here if you scroll all the way
down if you go to world you have all of
the assets that you've bought or claimed
i have all of these assets all of these
are free assets and they're amazing um
so try to check um the assets out and
maybe you might like something and make
a game out of it anyways i can go here
and hit launch and if it takes a while
don't worry i have my android version 5
installed on my hdd just because of how
big it is um usually i have the engine
on my hdd and then on my ssd is where i
have all of my projects saved
so you can do that you can have the same
approach or you can do something
different it's completely up to you but
that's usually what i do
uh it takes a it takes a long time to
open up unreal engine for me
essentially because of the biggest i
mean one i'm recording and two because
of the fact that uh for unreal engine
you need
pretty decent specs i have like
average specs for example you can see i
have a six core cpu and
memory when it comes to memory if you're
trying to make a game using audio engine
make sure you have at least 16 gb ram
don't try to create a game with 8 gb it
is not going to work out well for you
especially if it's going to be a high
scale game
and make sure you have a good graphics
card i have 2gb vram so i can barely get
through this um but if you if you're
trying to if you're purchasing a new
laptop or a new computer just for game
development make sure you have a good
cpu which is six cores at least or more
than six cores um it uses a lot of cpu
power so if i go to processors over here
you can see unreal engine is i'm hogging
up my cpu like crazy and if i go to my
performance again memory make sure you
have like at least 16 gb ram especially
under engine 5 you will not be able to
get through it i swear to god
but anyways let's go to games and
we have a lot of these templates over
here so if you want to create a really
quick prototype the best part about
unreal engine is that you can create
prototypes really really easily so um if
i want to create a first person
prototype i can instead of creating the
movement the projectile movement
everything from scratch i can just i i
can just use the template over here and
it will create it automatically for me
so i have my uh shooting part my
keyboard my uh
my joystick all of them built in so i
don't have to create it from scratch
now this this is very very useful when
it comes to game jams uh essentially
where you game jams are competitions
where you are given like a day or two
days to create a game and for those it's
very very useful so you can see i have a
lot of these different um projects i'm
going to be using the third person
except we're going to create the
animations um the game with the movement
logic everything from scratch so um
that's why i'm going to use the third
person and the reason why i'm using
third-person uh
uh third-person project and not a blank
project is because um i have a lot of
unreaction provides a lot of animations
and i need these animations in my game i
don't want to make my animations from
scratch which is why i'm going to use
the third person uh project
now under quality preset i'm going to
use to change mine to scalable i'm going
to enable starter content starter
content essentially like a bunch of
assets unreal engine gives for free like
textures materials um uh
particles etc
under project name uh make sure this is
on the blueprint not c plus plus there's
not a c plus plus close there's not a c
plus plus course um
the next then the next course that i'll
be releasing that's going to be a class
course of the same game
anyways i'm going to name this
batteryman
and create project this might take a
while um especially if it's your first
time this might take a while for me not
much but um
when it's compiling shaders that's when
it takes a very long time so if you have
if you have a project that has a lot of
different gameplay logic and assets
built into it um then it is going to
take a very very long time
especially because it has to
compile these shaders
okay now now that it's open up
you can see that we have this scene
every all everyone who opens up the
third person scene this is the default
scene over here i have the
the the floors there's a lot of cubes
the character blah blah blah um
let's try to go over all of these one by
one now i have the place actors tab
where i have different components or
actors that i can add on to my scene
what is an actor an actor is an object
that can be placed on the world this is
an empty actor and i can then add logic
to this actor over here
um now how this works is that everything
that can be placed onto the scene is an
actor so the box trigger is essentially
an actor look at it this way
a tesla model s for example is a car
it is an electric car but still the car
it derives from a car that's how this
works over here um the empty actor is
universal everything that can be placed
over here is enacted so this is an actor
this is an actor but we have different
types of actors so from an actor
something called a pawn is created a
pawn is an actor that can be possessed
possessed meaning it can you can add
input to this point over here for
example you can move the pawn like a
vehicle etc a character
is basically a type of pawn that can
move around so there's how the hierarchy
works
you have an active first under this
actor we have a pawn so the pawn
inherits from an actor and the character
inherits from a pawn it basically has
like a mesh collision etc let's talk
about collision shall we select this
third person character and in the world
outliner you can see that this third
person character has been selected
and on the world settings i have my game
mode override um we'll take a look at
all of this later but let's go to our
details panel
under details panel i have my capsule
component which is basically collision
uh the way collision works in games is
that you have a capsule you don't have
all these complex collisions like
you know the exact shape of the
character that is not going to happen
it's very very resource hungry um we use
simple collisions in our games and what
collisions do is it make sure it doesn't
walk through the stairs over here unless
you want to create a ghost um i can move
up these stairs i can uh jump i'm solid
the collision basically says okay this
object is solid but that does not mean
collision cannot be
you know
a collision cannot be uh cannot walk
through the wall it definitely can you
have different presets for example i can
say
my i can set my collision in such a way
that i can move through stairs but i
cannot move uh through a floor i can do
that i can definitely do that um all you
have to do is select the capsule
component
and once you select the capsule
component under in this part over here
we have different other we have
different attributes essentially like
the transform the shape the navigation
all of that um now the transform is
universal for every single game engine
we have the location the rotation and
the scale um the red is for the x-axis y
is for um
i mean the green is for y-axis and the
blue is for the z-axis uh you can also
see these arrows over here if i change
this red arrow if i if i hold this red
arrow and like move my mouse you can see
that my x-axis is getting changed the
same for my y and my set i can also move
two axis at the same time for example my
z oops okay that's pretty weird um i can
move my z and my y axis at the same time
really okay you know what i'm going to
move my x and my phi just because it's
simple uh you can see that my
values the corresponding values also
change um
so
when you're trying to place objects that
is you'll sort of have to understand how
to change all of these values now i can
also change the rotation if i press e i
can change my rotation so you can see
i can go up and down i can change
for example okay let's let's actually go
back um if i if i change the green part
over here you can see that i'm changing
my rotation with respect to my y-axis
same goes to the blue and the red that's
not waste time and the scale is
obviously the
the size of the character i'm going to
change this back to zero i don't want a
humongous character
oh okay now mine is supposed to be one
not zero uh if it's zero it's going it's
not going to have the x dimension at all
it's going to be a two it's going to be
a two dimensional object
capsule component if i uh i have
something called mobility and this is
present for every single um object so
for example if i select my network the
microstart a play start is essentially
it defines where my player should start
this is for it says network player start
so that's for multiplayer um so this
capsule component on the capsule company
if i have if i have something called
mobility it i can basically say if my
character should be static movable or
stationary um if i if my character
person gets some input and has to move
in one of these accesses or even rotate
i need to make sure that is movable over
here
uh i have my animations we'll be going
over all of this um later on we'll be
creating this from scratch
i have my mesh i can select if i want to
simulate physics or not and that gives
realistic physics i can enable gravity
or disable gravity actually you know
what try to change all of these values
and try to see what it does that's the
best way to learn to just explore um
explore and try to change all these
values hopefully you don't break the
engine
uh i have my capsule component so i
basically have different components
attached to my character and these
components have different attributes
like my for example my hair has
different attributes um my my legs have
different attributes but as a whole i am
a person so that is basically how this
works it it as a whole there's a third
person character and it has different
components attached to it i have my
camera etc
now you can see that it says it's
inherited over here it means my if i
hover over this it says my parent
classes character
what inherit
what i mean by inheriting means um this
actually a programming concept and what
this means is that the parent class has
a set of attributes that i inherit on my
child this is this third person
character this is not this is this
enhanced from the character class um so
you can see the pen class it says the
character class
um and the character class has the
capsule component the mesh um etc so i
don't have to if i create a child of
this third person character i mean
a child of this character because i have
all of these all of this built in think
of this as your think of your parents if
your if your friends have let's say
brown eyes the touch of you having blue
eyes is pretty pretty low um so you're
trying to inherit the dreams from your
parents and it's getting passed on to
the child that's how programming works
too and that's why it's so beautiful
now when it comes to the content browser
i have um my blueprints i mean the
content browsers used to navigate
through your game files
um
um and that's pretty much what it's used
for uh
and i have different folders this has
been created by unreal engine
automatically because of what template
i've chosen so if i go to blueprints i
have my third person character
before that let's first familiarize
ourselves with the place actors part two
if i go to i have different tabs over
here on the place actors i have my
directional light my point light over
here spotlight all of that so just like
real life um i can i can drag this value
into the scene and it has automatically
selected whatever object i've added
i can change all of these values for
example i can change the light color to
like
i know blue
red etc um i can change my intensity i
can either make it absolutely bright or
very very dark um so this cd stands for
can
whatever okay i don't know i i suck at
physics but anyways um that's what
intensity is for
my attenuation radius that's all of
these are physics light concepts um so
if you really really like physics you'll
probably be able to um
recognize all of these different
variables over here
uh unfortunately if you want to get
really good game development a little
bit of physics a little bit of math it
is important because
you know programming is essentially just
math
um and physics but
you know in a very very practical way so
it you don't need to know math physics
and all of that but it does help a lot
uh
you can understand the concepts a lot
better especially when you have to debug
something or add a completely new
feature
anyways let's not waste any more time
and let's create a new level so that we
can add our own um characters i mean our
own objects to the scene
if i if i click on my file i can go to
new level i'm going to create a default
level over here and it'll automatically
ask me to save this one over here
now
if i press ctrl s i can save this on my
folder i'm going to create right click
over here create a new folder called
scenes
um
and
i'm going to call this level one
actually yeah this should be called
levels i used to do this in unity a lot
it's supposed to be levels in unity to
recall scenes
there we go
okay i'm going to remove the floor and
the player start that they actually yeah
i'm putting it over the play style we
will add all of this
uh i have obviously i have something
called atmospheric fog which
well it has a lot of influence on light
but i can also add something called the
exponential height fog with which adds a
lot of depth to the map
actually try to uh try to explore over
here try to add different objects onto
your scene as i said but we'll be
creating something called a landscape
over here so i have something called the
landscape tab if i click on this you
have something okay
all of these clients that you see over
here uh this is usually called gizmos in
game development this applies for all uh
all game engines uh these lines they're
basically called gizmos and they're
basically outlines of whatever object
you've selected
uh the reason why i'm creating a
landscape and just not adding a cube
over here and scaling it is because it
is very very well optimized landscapes
are optimized for huge huge levels um
and i'll actually show you why over here
if i go to my landscape tab i can change
a lot of different values but all i'm
going to worry about is my section size
i'm going to make this seven into seven
quads
um so you can see it's seven over here
and seven over here i guess one two
three four yep there we go
um and i am going to create this
now the reason why i say this is very
well optimized is first off i can change
the depth of this landscape and you will
see in just a second
uh oh i forgot to um add a material but
no problems we can add that later on uh
it might take a while if especially if
it's the first time
for it to set everything up but
once you've hit create let's just wait
for a bit
okay you can now see this
huge white cursor over here let's change
the brush size to something small you
can see that i've selected it has
automatically selected the sculpt part
and i can basically add some depth to
this
map for example i can create mountains
over here and if i want to flatten it i
can select the flattened part and then
completely
flat smoothen this out
and flatten this to do the reverse of um
actually no
now this automatically selects the
sculpt part here
i can basically create mountains etc
smoothen well
it
it's pretty self-explanatory smooth and
set out um
and you can see that the shadows start
disappearing and it's kind of the
opposite of the sculpt mode
flatten
makes the uh land as flat as possible so
if i want to like add a river over here
uh i don't know if you guys are aware
but unreal engine has this amazing water
system uh so if i want to add like a
pond not a river that doesn't make sense
uh if i want to add a pond over here i
can easily do that
but the reason why i'm using the
landscape is because let me show you
something
let's actually go all the way let's
sculpt this part over here and let me
change the um
tool strength to like 0.4 so it's faster
you can see that it does not render the
graphics over here because it does not
have to like i mean why would i want to
uh render all of my graphics
the depth the complete height of this
graphics over here when the player is
not going to see it right it's all about
optimization uh now this is also one of
the reasons why you've seen in many
games if you have some collision issues
for example if i don't have collision
over here and the player just sort of
falls through the map if you keep
falling you can actually notice that you
won't be able to see the top of the
level that is because of the
optimization part of this landscape or
whatever they're using it applies to a
lot of different game engines it was
very very common in grand theft auto san
andreas um
and also cyberpunk um but anyways uh
that's pretty much why i'm using
landscapes over here and also because i
can use uh the the sculpt feature over
here let me just i i'm going to add some
depth i'm going to make this look like
an actual ground so that it's not
completely flat i find that really
really boring i hate um i hate when
objects are completely flat
so i'm just sort of going to do that
and let's
so you can see that it's it's editing
something called the height map the
height map essentially adds uh tells the
map where
how high
the level is for example um at this
coordinate
my
i have like a mountain of some sort and
over here i don't
so that's pretty much what it's doing
over here
uh now if i want to go back to my select
mode i can just click on my uh select
mode over here
and that is pretty much it
so if i select my landscape i can change
a lot of these values
what i'm going to do is i'm actually
going to create this again
because i didn't show you how to add a
material so when you go to your
landscape mode you can see this material
part over here
try to select the ground material
and
let's create it again and it's going to
be seven into seven so that's how you
add material and again i'm going to add
some depth over here just rub the sound
and make sure you have you you you click
your mouse don't just try to
run this around
okay that is that awesome uh now we've
created the landscape and also another
good part about this landscape mode is
that it scales the um texture
automatically for you so that it's not
just you know one part of the texture it
sort of scales it automatically so i
really really love that about
the landscape mode um
so try to add some lights onto your
landscape uh try to experiment on your
own try to change the light uh the the
color of the light or the intensity
whatever you want um and then let's try
to let's tinker around the exponential
height fog uh if i go all the way to
the top i can change the fog density to
make this really foggy um i want to give
this um a sort of martian like uh look
some sort of gonna uh make that red in
color
and yeah that looks really good
okay
um now let's
get into the coding part well it's not
exactly coding it's called something
called blueprinting and that's the
visual scripting uh language of unreal
engine and i absolutely love it
uh if you go to the blueprints folder
you can see the third person character
let's just double click now remember
uh this does not mean you can completely
get away with just blueprints you will
need c plus plus if you're making a
full-fledged game and releasing it why
because blueprints are are mostly meant
for prototyping and small features if
you if you have if you're trying to make
a multiplayer game for example you can't
get away with blueprints because
blueprints is not
uh exactly the fastest programming
language it is also programming language
but it's not fast c plus plus is a lot
faster which is why we're going to
create the exact same game game in c
plus plus later on
but that is a different course uh this
is only going to be blueprints as i
explained before
this might seem a little confusing for
you but actually these are two different
windows and if i go to my viewport over
here i can see my third person character
in action
and i can see my uh collide i can see
all of my components all together like
camera the arrow component all of that
let's try to take a look at all of these
one by one we've always taken a look at
the capsule component let's take a look
at the arrow component this basically
points towards the uh it points to the
front of i mean to the forward vector or
if it points forward all the time uh
let's take a look at the mesh the mesh
okay so now we have two different types
of mesh in unreal engine one is the
static mesh and one is a skeletal mesh
the static mesh is
used for stuff like um let's say a cube
for example if i drag this cube over
here you can see i have a static mesh uh
that's mostly because this cube is
probably not going to move and it does
not have any extra animations like i
mean what am i going to animate out of
cube maybe i can make this fall etc but
i don't need a skeleton i don't need
something called a skeleton for it
but i have something called the skeletal
mesh and this is the complex counterpart
for the static mesh
a skeletal mesh is essentially
uh a mesh with something called a
skeleton
now how animations are created is um you
have something called a skeleton and
it's assigned to a particular mesh and
you have the skeleton is of a bone and
then it's almost just like the human uh
the human skeleton over here
now
how animations are created is i i you
you take a specific bone and you sort of
change the values for example if i
rotate this bone over here i can sort of
create an animation i mean this probably
looks like i'm slapping someone but um
that's pretty much how animations are
created i manipulate the transform
values of this of these bones over here
like um okay not the middle finger maybe
the index finger um
and yeah there we go i can do that
um so that's pretty much what animations
uh how animations are created now you
can create animations in unreal engine
but i'd suggest you to if you want to
learn how to make animations there are a
lot of blender courses online uh by game
dev tv or uh
anyways there are a lot of different
there's a lot of blended courses online
please try to take a look at it it's
amazing
um
but this is the skeleton that unreal
provides us with i have something called
the camera boom now if i hover over it
this is the spring arm component and the
spring arm component essentially the
reason why we're not adding the camera
directly is because if i have a wall
behind and if my if my character is
moving behind if my character is moving
back
like that okay i had to move the capsule
uh i'll actually move the mesh if i keep
moving back and the camera moves with it
the camera might flip through the wall i
don't want that i want my camera to sort
of uh move up as the wall as i'm getting
closer to the wall uh which is what a
spring arm is used for it makes sure
that you the camera doesn't move through
the wall
now the follow camera is about the
camera itself and if you want to change
the position i'd rather change the
values of the target offset over here so
if i change it's like maybe 30 i mean
300 you can see it moves
uh with respect to the y-axis so i'd i'd
do it that way um anytime so i'm gonna
if i want this higher i can change the
socket offset and then press e change
the rotation like that um so that's the
way to go when it comes to making a
camera system
and i have the character movement this
is a built-in component uh created by un
created by epic games and um this
basically has different values that you
can manipulate for example the movement
values uh let's actually try to change
these if i search for my walk speed over
here um that's actually search for the
the maximum work speed if i change this
to like let's say
350 over here and if you want your
changes to
get saved you have to make sure you hit
on the compile button
and if i press alt b
you can see that i am walking
slower than usual so i can basically
manipulate all of these values and this
is again you can see that it's inherited
so this belongs to the character class
and this character class has all of
these inherited so i cannot read any of
these
let's let's change this back to 600 but
anyways it doesn't matter because we're
creating our own character
the event graph is where you create your
logic so these are all called nodes
and
you can basically drag and drop these
nodes over here uh to to create your
flow of the code
uh don't worry if this is very confusing
we'll be creating all of this from
scratch
and um yeah that's pretty much it for uh
the event graph and if i go to my
construction script this occurs even
before the uh even before the game
starts so if i want to add some
functionality to my game engine
i can do that in the construction script
uh in my event graph i have my variables
but let's take a look at the graphs i
can create different graphs for example
i can create a new graph just for
movement if i want to keep this very
very tidy
but we're not going to do that we have a
very simple script so that's fine
and we have something called variables a
variable is okay i'm going to make i'm
going to remove that available is
basically something that can contain a
value uh variables can be of different
types floats integers uh integer 64 byte
uh double let's take a look at all of
these
a boolean holds a true or false value
byte is an eight bit number integer is a
number bigger than the byte uh integer
64 is a 64-bit number float is a decimal
number so that's like 3.14 or 10.6 or
6.9 and double is a big 64 bit floating
now floating point numbers but it's like
6.99 nine subscribe and keep going on
until 64 bits of memory
a name is
a piece of text
a string is
basically any single um value that's in
codes for example
uh it could be my name or the the word
the the word hello or the sentence hello
world that could be a string um a text
is
well this is a different type of string
used for ui etc uh name is mostly used
for scene names level names all of that
vector a vector in physics is basically
a value that has a magnitude and
direction so i can say
x is moving at 10
or
10 meters square per second um in my in
the x direction so that's a vector and a
vector consists of the x y and the z uh
values
rotator is for rotation and it also has
the x y and z values um the transform
we've already seen it's the rotation
uh the rotation location and the scale
it is universal for every single game
engine
um so yeah that is the basics for the
blueprints now let's go ahead and create
our own character
so i'm going to create a new folder
first and i'm going to call this custom
blueprints because i don't want to
differentiate between the ones that um
fa games has created and the ones that
i've created and it's very important to
be organized now okay trust me on this
every single game developer will ask you
to be organized and they themselves will
not be organized this happens all the
time um but it is best practice since
you're just starting to learn try to
keep your project as organized as
possible now over here
i have my desktop icons
hidden but if i showed you you you'll
probably see how organized i am
make sure you don't make that mistake
try to organize your folders as much as
possible
under custom blueprints i'm going to
create a blueprint class and this is
going to inherit from my character so
i'm going to have every single
functionality that this character
provides for example i can walk around i
can add input but the code i have the
ability to do that but i need to make
sure i tell my character to move that's
like
you you have the intelligence to make a
game but you need to learn how to make a
game that's pretty much what we're doing
over here um so i have a character i can
select that and the name and convention
is usually bp underscore the name so i'm
going to call this battery man
um
and if i open it up i don't have the
mesh anything so if i go to my third
person character and try to compare it
all of these inherited parts i have them
on my bp underscore battery man um i
don't have the mesh because the mesh
isn't i mean i don't have the camera and
the spring arm component because that is
not inherited
so let's actually
uh copy these
and add them to our character over here
um oh actually it seems like yeah we can
copy them uh coffee and we can paste
them over here
so i already have my camera added or you
can just say add camera and add or
spring on component etc
okay i have my camera uh
compile and save and let's assign our
mesh so if i go to my mesh i can go to
my skeletal mesh i have only two of
these i have the female and the male i'm
going to use the male mannequin um
we're going to
bring this all the way to the bottom by
80 units actually let's do 90.
um
[Music]
actually no i think i think 80 would be
fine
over here and um press e
and let's
move that by 90 degrees
um and again that's the z axis compare
and save let's try to run the game
you may notice that i still have my
third person character and if you're
still confused as to what character i'm
using you can eject from this character
what does that mean
function uh just press f8 in your um
keyboard and then you can the game is
still running but i can basically debug
the scene over here now if you select
your third person character um you can
see that i'm still using my third person
character my player since pawn
and that sparks a question
how does the game engine know without
adding any functionality how does this
know that um i am adding i i want my
third person character to spawn that
doesn't even make sense right
um the reason is because i have
something called game modes if you go to
edit project settings let's take a look
at the maps and modes part
over here i have something called game
mode the game mode basically sets
default values for every single scene so
i can say no matter what scene i create
i always want my third person character
to spawn and in that scene i can say for
example if it's the main menu i can have
an override game mode which says okay
for the main menu don't spawn the
character because that's
weird
so i'm going to just have my ui etc i
don't want my character to spawn so
that's how unreal engine works so over
here on my default game mode i'm going
to change this value to vpn battery man
and now if i press alt p
i can see my character over here but
obviously i don't have any functionality
uh the reason is because i have the
ability to take input but i haven't done
anything with that input yet
so that's what we're going to add over
here if i go to my event graph
let's actually take a look at all of
these events over here which we haven't
seen before
i'm going to remove these
okay now the event play let's actually
see what this does the event play event
it
executes whatever code that's attached
to it in the beginning of the game so
only one it's going to get executed once
and that's when you begin playing the
game eventic it gets executed every
single second and let's actually take a
look at an example if i drag so this
over here is called the exact node and i
can release it to create to place a new
node and i can just say print string
over here
the way this works is when i call big
and play when they play place called
automatically and that time it's going
to print out this string over here and
i'm just going to say this is vegan play
compile
and let's play the game
alt p
and you can see that says this is this
is vegan play now
i'm going to add a player start the play
style essentially defines where my
player stood that uh my where my player
should start the game so now i don't
fall off the map
uh so now it says this is big and play
i'm going to now press alt and click
this button over here
and then move all move this to the
bottom
and then
drag the event tech node over here now
this can be anywhere but i'm just i just
asked you to get it bring it to the
bottom because i want this to be neat so
compile and save
um alt p and now you can see that it's
printed every single frame now remember
this might be different for every single
computer if my game runs at 60 frames
per second this function will be called
60 frames per second but in a different
person's computer let's say you have an
rtx 13 3080 and
your game runs at like 160 frames per
second or 120 frames per second then
this function will be called
at 100 120 frames per second that is how
the tick function works for unity users
this is like the start and the update uh
functions are very very similar so um
we're not we're actually not going to
use any of these because what we're
going to do is we're going to say if i
press my w key on my s or my a or my d
do
i mean move the character and if i press
let's say my mouse button print
something out that's what we're gonna
see over here
so
if i minimize this window go to edit
project settings
i have my
input part over here i have two types of
bindings over here one is the action
binding
action mapping and one is the axis
mapping action mappings are pretty
self-explanatory i just have my space
bar over here i'm actually not going to
bother adding but our game does not have
any jumping um
mechanics over here so we're not going
to add any jump but i'll actually i'll
show you how to make your player jump
um so this basically says if i if i'm
basically if i go back to my blueprint
right click and jump event you can see
under input action events i have this
jump and this button when i press my
button press my jump button do something
press if i release my jumper to do
something i watch the jump button the
jump button is my space bar and for my
gamepad is my face button
bottom button
anyways um i'm going to remove all of
these uh under engine obviously look it
seems like it supports a lot of
different consoles which is awesome
and my access mappings this gets a
little confusing i'm going to remove
everything i'm not going to use again
because it it gets very confusing for
our new developers so i'm going to do
more of these
now
if i press w i want to return a value of
1 which is basically going forward if i
press s i want to return a value of
minus one um and if i press a i want to
return a value of minus one if i press d
i won't return the value plus one why
because take a look at the axis if you
go forward it's usually positive if i go
backward it's negative so to my movement
input
i'm basically going to say add 1 to
as long as i'm pressing my w button add
1 to my
movement input and if i press a it's
going to add a value of let's say minus
1 at that particular direction um
so the why is it why is a minus 1 well
take a look at the x axis if you look at
the x axis the left part is -1
the right part is positive 1 so that's
basically how the coordinate system
works over here
uh turn rate uh what we're going to do
over here is we actually delete our turn
rate and turn
um
and our lookup rate over here
uh and what we're going to do is instead
of this we're going to call this uh
look light and then we'll call this look
up lookup is your mouse y
direction uh it returns a value ranging
from -1 and for look right if i move my
mouse in my x direction it returns a
value ranging from positive one let's
actually
see what that does
now in my input action
if i press this i want to print i am
jumping
so i can just
control let me compile save that go back
i can remove this now and alt p if i
press space it says i am jumping
and if i release this
if i go to my release part over here
i it's only going to print this out when
i release my button
okay now
let's try to bind all of let's add let's
start to add some functionality if i
right click and then
search for mouse x
make sure you get the event the events
and not the mouse values um so i'm going
to get mouse x and mouse by the events
so let's actually see what i mean by
when i say it returns a value ranging
from -1 so what i can do is from this
node i can print a string and this is a
float the green part is for float what
this is doing is it's giving an output
of or returning a value of a float which
is the axis value and if i drag this in
it's going to convert a float to a
string
if i compile and save go back
alt p
if i move my mouse
um
left and right actually that was mouse x
yes so that's going to be left and right
you can see my values are ranging from 1
to minus one uh i mean
it starts from one if i go right it's
going to be uh positive it's going to go
if i go left it's going to be negative
it's just keeps adding that value over
here
and the same goes you can try this out
for more spy i'm not gonna waste my
everybody's time uh trying to do the
same thing for most prime and it's gonna
do the same thing
um
okay so let's actually try to add our
mouse movement over here if i go to my
spring arm i have to make sure it always
says use pawn control rotation why
that's because when i change when i what
i'm going to do is i'm going to change
the control rotation of the pawn and
that's how i'm going to change the
rotation of the spring arm which
changes the rotation of the camera why
because the camera is the child of a
spring arm what that means is that if i
move my spring arm the camera is going
to change with it just like how um a kid
follows
his or her mom all the time that's
basically how the spring armor i mean
the parenting part works over here uh
same way the arrow is a child of the
capsule component that meshes the child
of capsule component etc which means as
i move my capsule component the mesh
moves with it
okay so we're going to change something
called the yaw and the pitch the pitch
is the y axis the yaw is the z axis so
with this axis value we're basically
going to add that value to the y or the
z axis let's see how to do that let's
drag a node
and we're going to search for it if it's
the x axis we're going to add the yaw to
it
why because the x axis if i'm going to
rotate with respect to my x x-axis over
here
that means i'll be rotating it
you know sideways i don't want that
right
so i'm basically going to rotate it with
respect to the
z-axis which is basically
left and right
so i can plug in this value over here
copy i mean i'm not gonna copy that uh
i'm just going to
do the same thing but for the pitch over
here so add control of pitch input
now keep in mind if i have this disabled
so alt and click that
if i don't have an exact node connected
it means this
this function will not get executed what
is the function a function is a chunk of
code which may or may not take an input
and uh it provides an output based on
that by processing it so you have an
input it processes that input calculates
that does something and it provides an
output the output here being um
the the camera getting the camera
rotating on the scene so if i go back
alt p
you can now see that i have proper
camera movement over here
now if your access is inverted like for
example if i go up i want to go down and
if i move down i want to go up if i want
to do that all i have to do is go to my
project settings again um
go to my uh input part and i can just
change my mouse by positive one
and uh if i alt p now
if i move if i move up i mean
that's the opposite essentially
okay
um let's open up the blueprints again
but we we did this for our mouse but we
need to add movement obviously to it uh
so let's do that now let's get on events
so our move forward event was basically
binded to the keys w and a i mean w and
s
so let's search for the axis event over
here and let's do the same for move
right uh the axis event so i have the
axis value over here for move forward
i'm going to add this axis value to
something called the forward vector of
the character the forward vector is
basically a vector that defines the
forward direction and here we're going
to add this to the right vector um the
right vector is essentially the the
vector that defines the right direction
um so if i right click and add
movement input if i search for this
i need the world direction over here the
world direction is
basically going to be get actor
um
uh
let's actually um get the rotation over
here so if i drag this
over here
get rotation okay get location
uh you get forward vector so this is
going to get this the direction is going
to be the forward vector because we're
going to where they're going to move
forward or back
and this takes an input as a rotation
now this is a variable
the forward vector is a variable and um
it's that if i i mean this is a function
the forward vector itself is available
this get forward vector is a function
and this does not have an exact node
which means it's a pure function it
returns a vector and i can add that to
the world direction the scale value is
going to be the intensity uh which
basically whether if i press w it's
going to return a positive value if i
press s it's going to return a negative
value and in rot it's basically the
rotation i'm going to get actor rotation
over here
and that's basically what it's doing is
basically doing some complex math and
then saying okay i know what the forward
vector is so move uh depending on that
direction
um
now the same thing over here and
movement input but this is going to be
for the right vector so
get right vector
and we're again going to use the actor's
rotation over here
so
that's that for um our movement and
that's pretty much it we're done with
movement so if i all p now
i can move left right forward back etc
and it works perfectly fine
but my character is still in this
v pose or the steep voice the reason is
because i don't have any animations
assigned
before that let's actually see how to
make this neat um now
okay
the the length of this node or this the
length of this line does not matter it's
not it's not going to affect the speed
at all just just adding that um i was
dumb enough to believe that the speed
was affected uh because of it
don't be like me it's not
but always make sure it's neat
make sure you can see which line which
axis i mean which way was getting
connected to what etc
that is very important
so compile and save now let's start
let's try to document our code over here
if i select all of this and press c i
can add something called a comment this
does nothing but it's just for us
for our understanding so i'm just going
to say add movement input over here and
over here i'm just going to say add
mouse input over here
now we're not gonna have we're not gonna
make our character jump but in case you
want to add the functionality i'll show
you how to do that um
if i right click and search for the jump
event so remember we have an actual
action event called jump
uh when i press this i want to start and
i am going to just jump and jump is a
built-in function of this character
class
so the character automatically starts
jumping and over here i can say stop
jumping because i don't want to keep
going higher and higher and higher so
alt p i have my jumping over here too
awesome
uh but i'm not gonna bother adding this
because i don't want this in my game
but
yes that is that for movement um now
that we've added movement the next part
is to add animations a lot of people
don't like animations i personally don't
like adding animation but unfortunately
uh it is a part of game development so
let's style it on how to do that
for animations i have a different
blueprint that i can add um so i i'm
going to put my content
part and new folder i'm going to call
this animations
and let's create something called an
animation blueprint now the reason why
we're using an animation blueprint not
the normal blueprint is because the
animation blueprint is optimized
especially for for blueprint i mean for
animations and it has
a lot of different functions built in
now to create an animation blueprint i
have to attach this or assign a skeleton
to it we've already seen what a skeleton
is um
so different animations are made for
different skeletons so make sure we
select the ue4 mannequin
which is the built-in skeleton
uh press ok the naming convention is abp
oops
again right click rename
abp underscore
um i'm just going to name this battery
man over here
double click
and now i have my output pose i have two
different graphs over here i have
something called the atom graph which
basically decides the output post and in
the event graph i can um
let's say get the speed of the character
and then change my animations based on
that uh that's what these two graphs do
the event graph is for all the
functionality like um getting the
variables adding uh values the variables
etc
the atom graph is to decide the output
pose
if i drag a node from here
and search for the run animation play
third person run and compile uh now this
over here takes an input if your if your
variable is on the left side it means
it's taking an input if it's on the
right side it means the node is giving
an output so the third person is going
to get the animation uh use the
animation pose as an output and
that output is sent as an input to this
output pose over here compile and save i
have to go to batteryman and assign my
animation blueprint so
i can either select my animation
blueprint and then hit this arrow over
here or i can just search for abp
underscore battery man now compile and
save
if i run this now you can see that my
animation is getting played continuously
i don't want that i want my idle
animations all of that i want a
different animation for strafing it it
just looks really weird so we're going
to create something called a blend space
for that let's take a look at what blend
space is
so go to animation
and search for blend space
and again you have to assign the
skeleton so this can be bs underscore
battery man
[Music]
okay now
let's open this up
and this might look a little confusing
but essentially the blend space has the
x-axis and the y-axis and depending on
the values of this
a certain animation will be played for
example let's take a look at the
vertical and the um horizontal the
vertical
i think the vertical is this one over
here um yeah that's the speed so that's
your vertical axis we're going to name
this the speed and name the bottom one
the horizontal axis the direction so
based on my direction and my speed i can
play a particular animation so my
minimum speed over here is going to be
zero my maximum axis value over here my
maximum speed is 600 as we set in our
movement component
my minimum axis value here is going to
be 180 my my maximum is going to be
positive 180 so
why positive 180 and negative 180 180 is
usually forward negative 180 is the
complete opposite direction um
so that's what we're doing over here
okay so
basically what i'm saying is
uh actually let's do this with an
example search and then this asset
browser search for your idle animation
and drag and drop this at the bottom
what i'm saying here is if my speed is
zero regardless of my direction make
sure you play the idle animation i'm
pretty sure you can now understand what
this is doing so if my speed is zero
then i'm going to play my angle
animation now you may understand where
to put your run animation it's going to
be all the way at the top now if you
hold shift and um
actually sort of move around you can
actually you can preview the animation
so if my speed is set if my direction is
at zero which is forward and my speed is
at 600 then i'm going to play that
animation and it slowly turns
it slowly adds the value so my animation
slows down as i go down and my preview
value if my speed is at zero regardless
of my direction i'm still going to stay
idle uh so that's what it does
now
if my direction is at 90
i want i want to make sure i move
left
so let's search for let's search for on
and actually let's take a look at all of
our animations over here
um
okay
uh so
what usually happens is we have
different animations for when the
character turns left and when the
character turns tight but
the animation the the animations that
come built in we unfortunately don't
have those animations so what we're
going to do is we're just going to add
run over here and remember when my
direction
is at
uh usually you'll have also a backward
run animation
uh so when the direction is at minus 180
and 180 you usually want your um
you want to move backwards so you'll
have a different animation for that and
you will add that respectively um
so let's just add this animation i
really don't want to do this but
uh
in our c plus plus course i'll make sure
we get um animations for moving right
moving left actually let's try deleting
the
all the other values let's just have one
for moving forward
if i save this
and alt p
okay obviously i need to assign this
blend space in the animation blueprint
because we still haven't assigned it yet
so if i go to my animation uh blueprint
i can drag a node and search for blend
space so now i can see my blend space bs
underscore battery man and this takes in
two inputs one is going to be the
direction one is going to be the speed
and based on that it will choose an
animation
which is what we said um
so from here i'm going to drag a node
and promote this to a variable so it
automatically creates a variable called
direction and it's a float and i'm going
to promote this to a variable and it's
going to be speed
compile go to my event graph now in my
event graph i can get the speed and the
direction so let's see how to do that
now from try get pawn owner what this
does is it tries to get the owner of
this animation blueprint um so
i can now cast this to my um bp battery
man why am i doing this but
that's actually that's mainly because i
have my pawn the pawn is the clasp but i
have to convert my clasp to my battery
man uh the way this works is if i go to
my bp underscore battery man and add a
variable i'm just going to call this
test variable
if i want to get hold of this variable
i can't get this from pawn i can't just
say get
test variable it does not exist but if i
convert this to a battery man and then
ask batteryman if i try get test
variable now i can get hold of the very
variable so we're trying to just um
uh localize
localize this pawn to my vpn scope
battery man
so from here we're going to actually
first what we're going to do is we're
going to check to see if we got our pawn
owner or not and that is done using the
s valid node
so
if i get my pawn owner if if i'm not
able to get my pawn owner i can just say
i can just print
a string saying
i
pawn owner
not
valid
now the reason why we're doing this is
because if we're trying to get a few
variables from the pawn owner we need to
make sure we have that pawn owner if not
your game is end up your game is going
to crash so this is the safer way of
doing it if it is valid what we're going
to do is we're going to cast to third i
mean cast to bp underscore um battery
man
and this has an exact node so obviously
this goes to s valid
as batman what we're going to do is
we're going to get a variable called get
velocity
so the velocity is obviously the speed
but remember velocity has direction and
magnitude
so from get velocity
we're going to get
uh we're going to calculate we're
actually going to get the
um
[Music]
we're going to get the vector length
the return value is going to be your
speed so
we only we already um promoted this to a
variable so we're going to set this
variable here
so
drag this variable onto your event graph
and press alt
and then you can just drag the return
value onto speed which means now the
value of the speed is going to be the
velocity the vector of velocity from
battery man
we need to obviously set the direction
to we're not done yet
so from here we're going to get actor
rotation
and from the rotation
we are going to calculate direction
so obviously for the direction you need
to calculate what you need to calculate
the velocity so from the velocity you
get something called the direction too
that's how
vectors work
and again i'm going to the same
direction
and i can set the value
after setting speed i'm going to set the
direction so the control flow is
basically
uh update animation this this basically
going to happen every single frame
uh from here it's going to go to s valid
it's going to check if the pawn owner is
valid if it is cast to be if you
underscore battery man so convert pawn
to battery man from here get the
velocity get active rotation
uh calculate the vector length calculate
the direction set the speed and then set
the direction
uh we can yeah actually when we keep
this over here
now we have the values for speed and
direction all you have to do is go to
your animagraph and you can see that it
as it has already set the direction and
the speed so now compile and save go
back
and if you press alt p
i now have my animations obviously it
does look a little weird that if i go
left and right
i don't have um proper animations but
that's actually going to be um actually
try to do this on your own uh search for
your left and right animations go to
your
go to this um blend space
when the direction is at minus 180 and
180 you want to make sure the character
goes backwards
and for your left and right animations
here you're going to place your right
animation here you're going to press
your left animation and check if it
works and if it does then you've
understood how blend spaces work but
we're gonna move on
uh the game as you've seen in the
beginning the way the game works is you
have a lot of different batteries all
around the map
and the health of the player keeps
decreasing and you have to make sure you
collect all of these batteries and if
you do then you go to the next level or
you win the game
so
let's see how to do that um this is
where we'll be learning about ui etc so
that's going to be there's going to be
the second part of the course uh if i go
to my blueprints my third person
actually normally third person obviously
it has to be my avp underscore battery
man
um i mean my bp underscore batch man
over here uh
we're going to create a new variable
called health let's remove this
and let's create a health available
uh over here i'm going to search for uh
i'm going to make this a float and
compile the default volume and the
default value i know what's going on
with me the default value is going to be
100 over here compile and save
now what we're going to do is we're
going to get our event tick
and every five seconds we are going to
reduce the health how do i do that drag
a node and then add a delay node over
here what this does is it's basically
going to wait for
um x amount they're going to wait every
five seconds
and
get this value so if you
drag this one into the screen and then
hit ctrl and then place it you'll get
you'll be able to get whatever value
you're health is
and we're going to subtract
so if i just
as you can see if i search for minus i
can subtract a value and i'm going to
subtract
a value of mine of 5 maybe so once i've
subtracted the value so let's say my
health is 100 if i subtract it the
output is going to be 95 and i have to
set health over here again set whatever
value
um i've returned and then once i'm done
i can just do that
now basically every five seconds i'm
going to reduce my health let's print my
health out every time actually
for simplicity i mean just make sure
it's faster i'm going to make it every
two seconds and drag and drop health
again convert it into a string and plug
it into my print string
compile and save
all p
now you can see it's 100 after two
seconds 95 and then it's 90
85 etc so it keeps going down
um what i'm going to do is i am going to
add some ui i'm going to add a health
bar so that this is connected to that um
i'm going to reduce my health every two
seconds but i'm going to reduce my head
by 10 compile and save
um
now i have to do something called
binding i'm going to bind this health to
my ui so let's take a look at how to
create ui
under blueprints i'm going to create a
new folder and call this ui
and under ui you can go to um
fx actually not fx um this is on a user
interface
and i'm going to create a widget
blueprint
the naming conventions wbp underscore
whatever name i'm going to call this um
player
ui
so
in this we have something called the
designer and in the design of this what
the ui is going to look like you can
design uh i mean you can basically place
all of these objects and you can make it
look like a proper ui we're going to add
something called a progress bar over
here
let's actually scale this
um
about let me make this
500
and i'm going to do something called
anchoring what this means is as i resize
my screen so for example if i minimize
my screen i want my i want to still stay
at the top left corner and if i make it
full screen it should move along with
the screen that's what
anchoring means so i'm going to make
sure it's over there
and
if i scroll all the way down
under style
i have something called the fill image
if i
if i'm
if i drop this down i have something
called the tint the fill image is going
to be
the the actual health over here so i'm
going to make sure my i mean my battery
my battery is going to be of green that
actually reminds me how to change this
to
battery
okay and make sure you save that here
and compile
and over here
our background image let's just
um make this
actually let's make that black that's
fine
and
we have to we have something called the
percent now the person ranges from zero
to one if it's one it's going to be
completely filled if it's zero it's
going to be
well empty um let's make the default
full
and we're going to do something called
binding it so you see this bind button
and you can select create binding and
what we're going to do is we're going to
get the health and we're going to set
that health to this percentage we're
going to convert the health into
percentage and then we're going to set
it over here so the return value is
going to be the percentage that's
displayed
so now
we can say get player character
and that's going to return whatever
character um i've processed we're going
to obviously convert this to my battery
man
so
once we've done that
as battery man we can just get our
health
i mean get battery
and then we can set that over here
but remember we have to convert this
into percentage because this person is
going to be between 0 and 1. so what
we're going to do is we're going to
divide this
by 100 remember by by definition percent
means per
cent cent is 100 so um we're going to
divide this by 100 and then return it
over here compile and save um now
we have to
add this ui onto the screen to do that
let's go to let's have our begin play
all of our ui will be insta instantiated
in bing and play
over here we're going to create a widget
so we're going to create an object of
this player ui
so i need to select which class that's
going to be my
wp player ui and return value i'm going
to add this to viewport so it's
basically going to add this player ui
onto the viewport and whatever function
i'm binding it's going to make sure it
executes all of that code so now if i
play
you can see that my percent bar is
slowly decreasing which is amazing um
and it has some amazing decal too so it
has some animated graphics so that's
very cool
that's why i love unreal engine it does
everything for you
and we can now remove this print string
now again we have to make sure it only
reduces the value until it goes to zero
and once it goes to zero i want to kill
my player
so to do that first off we're going to
decrease the value only if my battery is
more than zero
so if i drag control
we now can search for the greater than
symbol
and if it's greater than zero only then
execute this but how do we do that how
do we add conditions we do that by
uh something called a branch so you can
see that's red color over here so if
it's more than zero it's going to return
true if it's less than zero it's going
to return false so from here i can
create something called a branch
and
i can now add this to this branch now if
my health is more than zero then i'm
going to execute this
so i'm going to move that to the top if
my health is less than zero then i'm
going to say my player is dead so that
time i'm going to add um
a
retry screen etc and i'm going to make
sure i
um
do not possess this character anymore
but we will see that later on
um
but let's create a variable now let's
say b is player there that's the naming
convention for
uh bull boolean values you make sure
it's b is player that or whatever and
we're going to make sure this
compile
and the default value is going to be
false
and if i
hold alt and drag this onto the scene
we can set this to be true over here
awesome now if player is dead then
obviously i've lost so i'll use i'll
pull out my loose screen menu
and i can either retry the game or i can
play the game again
um
so that is the basic functionality that
we're going to use over here
once the player is dead what we're going
to do is we are going to we have this
function called detach from controller
bending destroy
what this does is it makes sure your
controls don't affect the player once
you have detached from um once you're
dead so if i
wait um and wait for it actually let's
let's make that faster uh i have no
patience um i'm going to make that 20 so
that as soon as i spawn in like four
seconds i'll end up dying so
that's
there
and
now you can see that you can try
controlling but you will notice that
your controls don't work and that's
because we have detached from this
controller and we need the animation to
stop playing so we can um
we can also have another
so we can we can either stop our
animation like this but this might not
work let's try that out
uh
let me make that funny because i don't
want to wait four seconds
um compile and save
all pay
now the animations are still playing so
we have to take care of this through the
adam montage i mean the animation
blueprint we have this variable here is
playerdead so we're going to get this
variable from our bp battery man and if
it's true we're going to stop animations
let's see how to do that we'll be
learning about a new thing called the
blend by bool
okay uh over here in this animal graph
we have seen before that we have
something called a branch so if the
condition is true do this condition is
false do that um instead what we'll do
is we'll say
just search for bull and says blends
forces by bull um
and post this by bull okay anyways um
if
so we can pass in a bowl value over here
and if it's true it will do this if it's
false it'll do something else now if a
player is not dead we want this blind
space if the player is there then we can
just um
maybe i know
we can play the idle animation over here
and how do we get this value same way
uh we have bp battery man we can also
say get
b is
is player dead
and we can promote this to a variable so
promote the variable and bring this all
the way to the top
and compile
now i think you can understand the rest
we can just drag and drop this over here
and now it's going to make sure if
player is dead then it's just going to
play the idle animation and not do
anything because we don't have fuel to
run
there we go that works perfectly fine
and after this we have to make sure we
display our player lewis screen now try
to do this on your own it might be a
little difficult but just give it a shot
if you can't no problems uh we're gonna
do it anyways
uh we're gonna create a new user
interface we're actually gonna create
two of them one is for player win one is
for player lewis
so we've wpvp underscore
um
actually we don't need
a blueprint a widget blueprint for win
because we're automatically just going
to go to the next level um
or we're just going to yeah we're just
going to go to the next level and here
we can just name this the
wbv loose screen
in the designer part i'm going to add an
image
first
let's scale this
completely so it fits this handle
um
and make sure we have
this properly aligned okay anyways even
if it's oversized no problems we're
going to anchor this to be
full screen
um
there we go so it's going to be it's
going to make sure it's always full
screen
and
i'm going to change the opacity to i'm
going to change the color to black and
the alpha to like
yeah that that looks fine we're going to
have two buttons now
the first button
is
basically going to be
one sec
um
give me a second item
okay the first button what it's going to
do is well
there's going to be the
retry
part so retry game
and we need to add some text to it
the same button i can duplicate it
and we're going to add this over here i
know it's not exactly aligned but that's
fine this is going to be quit game if
you want to quit
color and opacity um
seems just fine for me
yeah that's that seems just fine no
problems
okay uh now let's see how to add text to
this all you have to do is search for
text and drag and drop it it's going to
automatically pair it make this a child
and
under the text block over here we're
going to save the try game
or actually usually just says retract
and
under phone
i'm going to change the size to maybe
a 34
yeah that seems fine
and
for quit game again another text block
um we're going to make it 342
and we can just say
quit
okay
make sure i'm going to name this text
block to quit text
and this one is going to be
retry and we're going to have a huge
block of text over here
and this one we're going to name it
we're just going to save you is that's
that's pretty much it uh let me make
that 80 actually
and text block i'm just saying i'm just
going to say you
lose
okay awesome uh
in my graph i have to make sure i add
functionality to this to these buttons
so if you scroll all the way to the
bottom after you've selected the button
we have on click and on press we're
going to use the on pressed
because it works better for example if
you press enter by mistake it might just
uh end up retrying the game we don't
want that we have to make sure we click
on the button so that's why we use on
pressed do the same for retry game too
i mean for quit game
uh not on click on pressed over here
and for retry we're going to open we're
going to load the level we're going to
load the exact same level so that level
is going to be
get
level get current level name because if
it's a different level if it's level two
then it has to make sure it has it opens
up that level so get current name
ensures it gets the proper level the
level that you're running right now
and we're going to open that level so
it's basically going to open the same
level again with all the default
settings
for quit game
it's literally just one node
quit game that is it compile and save uh
now if i minimize my screen alt p again
we have to make sure we added the
viewport so if i go to my blueprints
if my player is dead detach from
controller pending destroy that's fine
and whatever we did here
we're doing the exact same thing
over here
but the problem is remember this is on
thick and when we create when we put
this on take it means it's going to
create the player widget every single
frame and add it to viewport every
single frame which means your game might
end up crashing so we're going to add a
node that says do once this means that
it's going to whatever that comes after
it's going to do this only once
um we're going to
we're going to make sure we print we
create the loose screen widget and then
we're going to add to viewport now if
you compile and save it let's run the
game
and now it says you lose but the problem
is we cannot use our mouse
we can only you know we have to press
windows etc
so if you want to show the mouse cursor
get your player controller anything
related to controls that's present in
the player controller
and over here search for cursor
let's see what we have over here
we have get show mouse cursor set show
mouse cursor so we can set this by this
value is present in the player
controller we can set this to true now
if i compile and save this
and minimize
and we're running around and now i can
see my cursor if i press retry
it loads the same level again and i'm
losing and blah blah blah so it
basically restarts the level
okay awesome we've done all of that um
now let's see how to convert these into
functions functions are basically blocks
of code
made into one chunk of an object which
you can call later on for example if i
right click on all of this collapse to a
function
um okay collapse into function phase
let's see why is that okay delay cannot
be okay
some
okay let's just create a test function
over here
test function so this function can have
a lot of different functionality for
example imagine i have a thousand nodes
in this graph over here if i go to event
graph if i'm if i want to call this
function again like in ten different
positions
what if
it makes better sense for me to call
this function rather than creating those
thousand nodes again and again and again
that's going to look very very dirty
which is why i'd rather put those
thousand function those thousand nodes
in one function
and then i can call this function and
delays cannot be added in a function so
if i right click over here i can just
collapse this to a function and i can
say reduce
health
and this function we know that reduces
health if i double click on this it does
the exact same thing over here
now
if you want you can convert this to a
function too i'm going to leave it we've
done that for it now the main functions
for maybe made the function for reduce
health but i'm going to leave um
uh the player death part as it is
but i can maybe add this part to a
function um but that just depends on you
or i can just collapse this to a node so
collapse the node player depth
um
so this is basically just it's still in
an element graph it's not it's not a
function or anything but we're just
making this part of the code faster
i mean uh shorter so that we can
find out what's going on
um
okay
so now let's create a variable called
batteries collected this should be an
integer why what we're going to do is
we're going to have
a maximum number of batteries per level
for example this level will probably
have eight different band eight
batteries and once we've collected all
batteries we're going to check if the
number of batteries we've collected is
equal to the number of batteries that
are supposed to be collected and if it
is equal then we can say the player has
won the game and moved to the next level
or we can just display windscreen but in
this case we're going to just move to a
new level and you can add all the other
functionalities so once we've reduced
health this part means the player has
not died yet as you can see over here
so what we'll do
is after reducing the health we're gonna
check to see if the number of batteries
we've collected
is equal but actually we're not gonna do
this in the player we're gonna do this
in something called the level blueprint
so
if i go to my level if i get a hit on
blueprint and if i hit on open rebel
blueprint this is a different type
blueprint it
is for the level itself and it can get
access to every single object that's
present in the level and i can add
functionality based on that for example
i can let and i can get the character
that's present in this level and then
check to see how many batteries he has
collected and and check to see if the
number of batteries have collected is
you know um
equal to the number of batteries that
are supposed to be collected and then
uh change to the next level
so let's try to do that first off in
begin play we're going to get hold of
our bp underscore battery man so get
player character
we're going to cast it
to bp underscore battery mount so we're
going we're going to convert our
character to the battery man
and then as battery we're going to
promote this to a variable
so that we we have a reference to our
player at all times
and in tech
so
now we'll be introducing something else
but before we we start making our win
conditions let's actually implement our
batteries observes so right click create
a new blueprint and this is going to be
an active
fifi underscore battery
if i open this up
i'm going to add something called
a
box
and i'm just going to add actually let
me just add a cube over here
if i scroll all the way to the bottom
okay i'm adding a cube this is going to
be my battery um your
try to try to
try to
change the static mesh to something else
maybe try to find a battery asset and
change the mesh to a battery but i'm
going to leave this as it is uh we're
going to scale it so if you want to
scale it press r
i'm going to make this flat
something like that okay awesome
now what we'll have to do is um let me
change the material to maybe
uh i've seen this really cool material
that unreal engine has
it has this
very cyberpunk like texture there we go
i love this texture
i'm going to make it this
okay
now if i scroll all the way to the
bottom we have a lot of different events
what these events are is that when the
component is hit do something
when someone overlaps the component do
something when an object has ended
overlapping do something that's
basically all these events are um that's
what these events do let's try to take a
look at the on confident hit event
called when a component hits something
solid so if this component hits maybe
something solid like another cube or a
player what is it supposed to do that's
how projectile bullets work in game
development too let's try to take a look
at on component hit if i press on if i
click on the plus symbol
i have something called the hit
component and the other actor the other
actor is going to be whatever actor that
has collided or hit this cube over here
and we're going to cast this to our
battery map
now not the battery the battery man so
search for battery man
now if this is true so if i have cost if
i have hit the battery man
then we're going to get the health
and get the battery
and then we're going to add
maybe let's say we're going to add an
amount
that actually let's make this a random
value so drag a note from this and ha
and there should be
um there should be
a node that says random float in range
we're going to we're going to add a
value between 5 and 10 so this is going
to return a value of 5 and of a number a
random number between 5 and 10.
and from battery we're going to set
battery again
and then we can drag this in
now if i compile and save let's see if
this works and i have to obviously
destroy this object because i don't want
to cheat so i can destroy the actor
which means it's going to um get deleted
from the scene
if i place this object over here
and move this to the top maybe we can
add some light to this but
oops okay i have to make sure i the game
isn't that difficult for me
so i'm going to change my battery value
back to 100
compile and save
alt p
if i move towards this battery you can
see that my health has increased over
here let me show you again my battery
so you can see it's slowly increased
which is what we're going to do over
here now we're going to make sure we
keep increasing our battery uh for our
player over here
let me go back to my bp underscore
battery let me add a light over here
point light um
and make sure you raise it to the top
because if it's inside the object you
won't be able to see it
and
we can make it red in color
okay compile and save
now
here comes the interesting part
this is where we make our win conditions
so
over here
once we've added health i added okay why
do i keep calling it healthy once i've
added battery to our battery man we can
add a variable to the batteries the
player has collected
so
again get the batteries collected over
here
and we always have to set it to set
batteries collected
i hope this doesn't get too confusing if
you do then try to make try to do a
little bit of math in a in a different
project on your own by getting values
from a player and casting them and
you'll be able to understand them in no
time i'm going to add one to the number
of batteries collected so if i let's say
i have three batteries already collected
i'm going to add one to it so that's
going to become four i'm going to set
the batteries collected and then i'm
going to destroy the cube
compile and save
now in my level blueprint i have to make
sure i define
what is the maximum number of batteries
right
um so let's try to do that
now right click we're going to take a
look at something called the game
instance
so let's take a look at game instance
over here
now gi underscore battery
man instance i just want to call it that
so in this instance what a game instance
is that it is an object that persists
persists through every single level so
this object will be there in the main
level in the in level one level two
level three this this is going to
persist in every single level so we can
add a few variables that says okay if it
is level one then uh make sure the
number of batteries is let's say eight
and then level two it has to be ten etc
now this is not the best way to do it
but
uh since this is a very beginner
tutorial we're not going to go over
gameplay like proper gameplay mechanics
so i'm just going to add a variable here
so level one
win
batteries actually no
max
batteries
one so this indicates for level one this
is the maximum number of batteries we're
going to make it a float and let's let's
let's set this value to eight now if you
want another level let's say level two
you can see max batteries too etc
now go to the level blueprint and you
will have to do this for every single
level but in tick what we can do is
we can right click get game instance
we have to cast this to our battery man
instance cross bi battery man instance
and again we can do this in begin play
because we don't want to clock we don't
want to cast this every single frame
and then we can promote this to a
variable
gi battery
map
okay
now from the battery man
instance what we can do is we can get
max batteries for one
and then from our battery man the player
itself we can get get batteries
collected
we're going to check if these are equal
now i forgot to make this an integer
so let's make sure this is an integer
compile
and save level one
let's check to see if these are equal
so
i can if these are equal then
i can basically say so again we have to
create branch so we're creating a
condition over here
so if we create a branch event tick
if these two are equal then i've won the
game so i can just end up opening the
next level or again i can
i can
have a win screen or whatever we're just
going to open another scene for this one
and let's call this level the next level
whatever
uh for example this one's going to be
level two you will have to do this for
every single
game level but remember in the c plus
plus course since that's going to be a
more advanced course we'll take a look
at how to make this a lot more scalable
in the sense how to make sure we just
add the logic once and we don't have to
keep copy pasting our code on and on and
on um now that we've created the game
instance we have to make sure we set it
in our project settings so go to maps
and modes and if you scroll all the way
down our default game instance has to be
gi underscore battery instance
let's create another level over here
so
again
new level
this can be a default level
and save it
we're going to call this level 2
and that's pretty much it i
we're all we're done with all of our
code mechanics now if i play the game
and
let's say our maximum is going to be one
so if i open up my game instance over
here my maximum number of batteries is
going to be one for example
save the game
and if i play now
we now move to the next level so that's
how we make our wind conditions now all
you have to do is decorate your level
maybe add a few obstacles and maybe like
a few cubes that distracts the player
maybe try to make this into a maze um
get a few assets from the marketplace
and try to make it in such a way that um
uh
maybe it's like in a spaceship and the
player has to find all the batteries um
from the spaceship which would probably
look really really cool but now i have
five different batteries here so i'm
going to go to my game instance maximum
batteries is going to be five
over here
compile and save
and save it okay
now let's see if this still works so alt
p
i'm going to collect oops it seems like
i have to
uh make sure this is all the way to the
bottom
so all the way to the bottom
all the way to the bottom okay alt free
now let's see
so first my battery does keep increasing
so that's pretty cool but
okay i might actually lose this i'm not
really good at games
okay
okay we seem to be we seem to win the
game that's awesome and
yeah that's pretty much it for our win
events now let's say your level two is
your last event what you do is in your
level two level blueprint
uh so if you open up the blueprint just
have the same condition that as you had
in level one except if it's equal you
create a new widget
uh your windscreen for example and then
you display that with screen onto the
scene for example if i go to level two
now let me actually show you how to do
it real quick
so if i go to level two open my level
blueprint now again try to do this on
your own please don't try to copy
whatever i'm doing uh that's why i don't
want to show everything because i want
to sort of make sure you guys get it on
your own uh what you do is you will get
your game instance again
you will cast this to battery instance
and we're pretty much doing the same
thing we did before
um
and remember if you have level two your
level two
level blueprint open you can't open your
level one level blueprint
it's going to get closed automatically
so we're going to promote this to a
variable
and
same thing
the same thing happens except it's going
to be for our player character so get
player character
cast to battery man
so basic converting it to battery man
and then
promote variable
and then we can get
max
i mean get batteries collected
and we can use this to compare so
in our event deck what we'll do is we
can get these two
uh
get batteries one so there's going to be
so we have to create a new condition for
level two
so all you have to do is control c
control v uh rename this to max
batteries too i'm just going to make
sure the max battery is just something
low like one for my level two
um so if this is equal
to the number of batteries i've
collected not battery number battery is
collected
batteries
collected
awesome
if this is true
what's going to happen is
um i can just
print out
i can create a new widget there's going
to be my winning windscreen
over here which is going to be going to
have a text that says you win the game
and then um
it's going to have a quick game
and then over here we can say cast to
i mean and to viewport
now if you try to compile
well it has an error over here because
the create widget class has to be
specified so let's create a new uh ui
element over here so ui
um actually let me just let me
let me duplicate this wbp underscore win
screen
now instead of lose we can just say
you
win
and we're going to load out for retry
we'll load the first level
and actually let's have the return to
main menu part in this
um
main menu
and in quit game
yeah fit game is going to be the same
now in the graph
open level for
uh we have to make sure we rename
everything because we just duplicated it
so for retry game over here we have to
make sure this says main menu now
it's just for simplicity's sake now when
you press the main menu we want to open
up the main menu so we're going to
create a new level called main menu
obviously compile and save because if i
go to level 2 i can just
create the when screen and make sure you
get the player controller
so get player controller
show
mouse cursor
we're going to set it not get it so show
mouse cursor set it
we are going to set this to true
compile and save
now
we have the main menu
we have the main menu part and that's
pretty much it
so
my condition for
my second level is going to be two so i
just need to collect two batteries and i
win the game
so
over here we're going to end up adding
batteries again
we'll add two batteries
if i play the game now
collected one collected two
and doesn't seem to be working let's
take a look at what's going on
okay the reason why i wasn't working was
because i
i got the
variable for the first level so we're
going to get batteries
over here and make sure we set that
now it's going to work so if i compile
and save and again remember we have to
make sure we detach from
uh
so okay if i go back to my battery man
you see we have detached from pending
destroy over here we're going to do the
same thing over here that's because as i
move my mouse i don't want my camera to
move to in my
windscreen so
let's see let's actually see if we can
get this on our own so detach from
nope
i'm not able to get that
get that particular node so let's see if
that's present in our clear controller
no it's not present in a player
controller which means it should be
present in our character himself
detach from controller pending destroy
there we go
we can do that compile and save so this
means we cannot control our player
anymore so once i collect these two
batteries
it says you went
and again one more problem this is going
on in tech so we have to make sure we do
this only once we don't want this every
frame it's going to crash your game
which was about to crash my game
um
so we have to make sure that's only
that's done only once if you want you
can make put all of this in a function
and yeah we're going to save this
go back all fp
collect the first one second one we win
quit game
and we're done with the game
awesome now
obviously this is not the best way to
make a winning condition but if you want
to
don't worry about making it the best way
possible the first time you're trying it
um
either the the main the main point is to
understand how blueprints work first and
then in the next course which is why the
next course is going to be a more
advanced course where we'll be learning
proper winning conditions all gameplay
principles etc
now we have one more thing remaining and
then we're finally done with this course
which is going to be our main menu
so
if i i had to create another widget
blueprint wbp underscore main menu over
here
and
i'm going to add an image again
let's make this full screen
and anchor it make sure that's full
screen
and now what we're going to do is
let me change this to black first we're
just going to have two buttons one is
going to be play game one is going to be
quit game that's pretty much it
uh and i'm pretty sure this is
self-explanatory uh i'm pretty sure most
of you guys will be able to do this on
your own by now but if not no problems
don't feel demotivated it's completely
fine it's normal
so we're going to say play game over
here
duplicate this control actually yeah
control w that's the duplicate
and
oops
we go
they're going to make this
we're going to call this good game and
obviously you can have another um you
can have another
um
button that shows the controls etc
over here
let's add some text
text to both
um play game and do it game i added it
to the image by mistake so i'm going to
remove that
this is going to be called play game
this is going to be called load game
and obviously we want to change the size
to like maybe 34.
it's not going to be played games make
quick game over here
and
over here again go back to the font make
this 34
compile and save
how do we tell the editor that whenever
we open up our project or the game we
need to make sure it opens this main
menu level to do that go to maps and
modes
and you can see your editor startup map
and your game default map what i'm going
to do is i'm going to create a new level
and make sure it opens up the main menu
over there
now open up a new level
actually we don't need to make it a
default level we can just create an
empty level over here
and ctrl s you can see that's completely
dark because there's nothing in this
level we're going to call this the
main menu
over here what we're going to do is
open up your level
blueprint
before that we have to add a game mode
override because as i said it doesn't
have to so if i run this game now
it's going to okay alt p
if you see it spawns up it spawns the bp
underscore battery man we don't want
that obviously
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add a game mode override over here
which means for this level alone it's
going to create a different game mode
and it's going to use that so under
custom custom blueprints i'm going to
create
um
gm underscore main menu
and over here
under default pawn it's going to be none
under how i'm just going to have all of
this normal
now
under blueprints open level blueprint
again we're going to do the same except
this is going to be in big and play
so create widget
and what we're going to create is the
main menu
and add to viewport
compile and save
now if i go back to
my project settings
if i scroll over scroll down here i have
my editor startup map
i'm going to keep my level selected
over here so
content
levels main menu
i am going to hit this arrow and it's
going to automatically assign my main
menu
now let's play the game
if i press play game nothing happens
that is because we haven't added
functionality yet so if i go to main
menu select this button again screw all
the way to the bottom on pressed you
know what to do
open level
this is going to be
level one
and
if
if i go to quit game on pressed again
um we can just quit the game
now make sure in our level 2 level blue
in our windscreen level blueprint it the
the level is named properly so if that's
main menu without a space compile and
save and let's just have a simple play
through now so if i alt
play game
i have my hud and you you may not be
able to see pics of that okay there we
go
uh we're gonna try to collect all of
these on time
and that's level two
and level two we're gonna we're gonna
get these two and now we win the game
and we can quit the game that is pretty
much it now we have a tiny little bug
over here
the the animation keeps playing
for
um
the animation keeps playing for our uh
well in our level 2 after we win the
game because we haven't added a win
condition in our animation blueprint
so what we're going to do is we're also
going to add another variable
and this variable is going to be called
the
as layer
1.
now in beginplay i'm going to make sure
i set this value to false and make sure
this is a bool
so we're going to change variable type
close compile and save and make sure we
set this to false every single time we
start playing the game
over here in my level blueprint again
what i'm gonna do is in level one
let's see if selected
blueprints open level blueprint
and
we have to make sure we get this
character
uh from the from the character over here
uh set
player one has player one over here
if it's true then
we can set
we can actually we have to set this only
in level two not our level one because
our player hasn't technically won the
entire game completely yet
so if i go to level two
open up my level blueprint
i have the same thing over here too now
if i
if i from the
on the battery man i have to set
one this search for has player one
i'm going to double click on this node
so that i can redirect this node over
here like that
move it all the way
to the end
and then
connect this we're going to set this to
true
i'm going to again add another
node over here so we can direct it
properly so it looks a little neat
compile and see
now let's open up our um
our
animation blueprint
i'm going to open that up
okay over here now we're blending spaces
we're blending forces by google over
here now if player is dead they're going
to
play the idol animation but if the
player is dead or if the player
has won the game we're still going to
play the idol animation
so over here we're going to have
an old boolean what this does is it
checks if one of these pool so it takes
in two bowl values
and if it cannot be stick a lot more it
can take
five six etc but we just need two of
these so we're gonna remove pin
remove pen over here
if the player is dead or if the player
has one play the player dead animation
so to get that
cast to battery man we've already done
that
from here we will get
one has clear one
move this all the way to the bottom and
again we're going to promote this to a
variable
the name is fine
and all the way to the end there we go
that looks a little neat
anim graph
place this over here so if any one of
these conditions are true we're going to
play the idle animation
so
if i now play the second level
one
two
see now my animations don't play
continuously so i can now quit the game
and that works perfectly fine awesome
now that is pretty much it for this game
your challenge is to add your own map
try to add your own level go to the
marketplace get there a lot of free
assets that you can use
maybe make this into a spaceship and try
this out
the only problem now is that
unfortunately since unreal engine 5 is
still under development
most of the assets are not compatible
with the engine so if i go back to my
epic games launcher and if i try to add
this free asset that i got from the free
for the month thingy if i click on show
all projects and try to select unreal
engine 5 you can see it says asset is
not compatible so what you'll have to do
is
you'll have to downgrade this project to
unreal engine 5 um and then you will
have i mean unreal engine 4 and then add
the assets but the problem is you might
have a lot of issues after upgrading it
back to unreal engine 5 which is why it
is still in early access not a lot of
assets are still
available for um unreal engine 5 which
is yes it is a little disappointing but
at the same time they've specifically
mentioned this
engine is in early access um so don't be
too worried you can follow the exact
same tutorial that i've showed over here
in unreal engine 4 it's the same
functionality same blueprints all of
them work perfectly fine it's just that
the ui might look a little different um
this looks a lot more modern than unreal
engine 4 that's the only difference i
could pretty much find for now when it
comes to at least
the basic parts so this tutorial can be
followed in unreal engine 4 2 so don't
worry about that
but thank you so much for watching i
really hope you learned something and i
hope you were able to familiarize
yourself with unreal engine 5 and game
development if you completed this course
that is amazing try to add your own
functionality to it if you want to learn
c plus plus stay tuned because i have a
c plus plus course coming very very soon
we're going to create the exact same
game but in c plus plus so that is going
to be very very fun but thank you so
much for watching and i will see you
very soon
bye and good luck